for a while you know the city was just
like this national joke and no wonder
you know with the river catching on fire
and Johnny Carson always make jokes
about Cleveland and you know Friday it's
just o'clock downtown to be empty like
nothing happening I would like everybody
in Cleveland to have like rich kids
syndrome but they feel guilty you know
that they had all these opportunities
and they have to go to Nicaragua now to
do some work in the summer when they're
off from college to make up for it the
Sun Belt is attracting people because
they have lower taxes and have a youth
development programs and the Rust Belt
cities but Cleveland won't change they
have the centralized idea of a
centralized government central control
and they don't want to give it up it'll
work out on its own I'm telling you that
Adam Smith and visible hand is a really
good thing there's nothing to be afraid
of Phoebe price is right and Cleveland I
would love to do that I hate I hate Los
Angeles